we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p here's a
question about an interesting scenario
that could present itself if Donald
Trump loses in November take a listen
hey David
question as far as likability on this
one but what are the chances that if
Trump loses in this election it's Joe
Biden they have four years by them for
years whoever else is there a chance you
think that Donald Trump tries to run it
yeah I'm just a hard no on this I I
believe that if Donald Trump loses in
November that's it in politics for him
Donald Trump will be what he'd be 78 78
79 when he would assume a presidential
term in January of 2025 I just don't
don't see it and Trump said if he loses
he's gonna go and work on something else
so I don't believe we're going to see
that whatsoever I think you're not going
to see Trump go peacefully if he loses
in November but we've already talked
about that but I Trump Donald Trump 2024
I don't see what one of his kids may try
to do then that's that remains an open
question on the bonus show today we will
talk about our respective little
vacations that we had last week we are
going to talk about the house passing a
bill for Washington DC statehood very
very interesting and and much to discuss
we will also talk about Sasha Baron
Cohen crashing a right wing event and it
has led to so much chaos once again all
of those stories and more on today's
bonus show get instant access to the
bonus show by becoming a member or a
patron membership is join pakman.com
patreon is patreon.com slash david
pakman show I'll see you then